here for reaction co-host of the five
geraldo rivera along with fox news
contributor joe koncha you know geraldo
you kind of have really worked hard you
you've tried to thread the needle to
defend joe biden
um
tell me what tell me where he's
successful
what do you look at as a success
let me first say sean one of the reasons
we are friends you and i is that you
have never confused me with the taco no
soy
i think that uh i feel i feel terrible
that jill jill by dr biden
really did such a terrible she also
massacred bodega any any new year she
couldn't say bodega
it's not a bodega not a bodhiago
democrats
democrats are frightened they're
frustrated they're angry they're bitter
uh they uh they don't understand why uh
joe biden is doing so poorly they blame
it now on his age and he is you know
more frail than he has been uh but i i
also think that when you shake it all
down and despite the alarming stories
and the fact that uh so many democrats
are turning on biden including the new
york times and new york magazine
bastions of the liberal establishment it
seems to me
i think that in a head-to-head between
biden and trump i think that the
democrats would say anybody but trump
and we'll take biden however if we have
to carry him in on uh you know on a
stretcher
i i
don't know why they have unforced errors
though sean i don't know why they can't
seem more competent you know the price
of oil is going down finally inflation
is pretty uh you know didn't go
skyrocketing beyond the 8.5 that it was
i i don't think that they understand
really that they are in charge and they
can make it work and they have to have
confidence
uh and and rally around their guy rather
than now you know uh you know looking at
them and seizing their every malaprope
uh just as if they were republicans sean
you know the thing is joe concha
joe biden is actually implementing
everything that his party wants him to
implement so it's sort of like firing
the coach because you can't fire the
whole team i don't see that he's he's
deviated at all
in in in any on any major issue from the
bernie biden manifesto from the from the
you know aoc squad agenda i think he's
doing everything they want it's the
agenda that's failing
and yet they're blaming him they want to
get rid of him because why he's
embarrassing them on a daily basis
well precisely sean i keep hearing about
now suddenly joe biden's too old to be
president when 18 months ago when he was
running for president then it was
perfectly fine and it's almost an excuse
that well if not for his age then maybe
things would be going better no it's
always been about the policy it's always
been about the perspective and the
things they want to implement like
saying if we spend trillions of more
dollars on top of the trillions we spend
that will lower inflation in the deficit
it's actually an argument that this
president and this administration makes
which is complete and utter nonsense and
look joe biden having these numbers
quite frankly is one of the least
surprising things we've seen in modern
politics i mean this is a man who was
profoundly below average in terms of a
student and oh by the way was a serial
plagiarist all the way back to law
school at going through to the first
time he ran for president and then
beyond that when he was a senator he
tells tall tale after tall tale as if
he's you know brian williams meets jesse
smollett of politics and he failed
upwards through the senate to the vice
presidency and all the way to the
presidency and now he's polling lower
easily than any first-term president
from truman to trump and when two-thirds
of your own party is begging you not to
seek a second act and running for
re-election that shows you he really had
no base in the first place and when you
break down the numbers by age by the way
in this new york times poll 94 percent
of voters under 30 do not want to see
him run for re-election so just like in
sports one would think that a team of
the horrible losing records would start
firing some people make some changes
show that you care but instead we still
see chief of staff ron claim we still
see pete butterjudge running
transportation when he can't get a
flight out and supply chains messed up
we still see the director of homeland
security and alejandro mayorkas and we
see what the borders become and the same
energy secretary and jennifer granholm
which i still don't quite understand
what qualifications she had in the first
place for that job so if this president
was truly in charge at least one or two
of those folks will be gone given their
performance right unless
in charge at all sean
let me go geraldo back to the new york
times and this by the way is not the
first piece they've done on his age and
how he really should not be the
candidate in 2024 he often shuffles when
he walks
promptly concerned he's going to trip on
a wire his speeches are flat and
listless he stumbles so often during
them as staffers are holding their
breath to see if he can make it to the
end without a gaff he regularly makes
huge policy change announcements that
are instantly walked back by the white
house like vowing a u.s military
response if china
invades taiwan or saying vladimir putin
cannot remain in power and will use
whatever methods they use has trouble
summoning names he appears momentarily
confused uh you know he makes one
mistake after another but doesn't it
negate the fact geraldo
we've known that since the beginning you
know we've chronicled that as a matter
of fact you've actually been somewhat
critical at times about me
saying that he's old decrepit weak frail
in a cognitive mess you get angry when i
say it
but now everybody's saying it you should
say i should get a pulitzer prize for
being first
the only good thing about getting old is
it's better than the alternative
and watching the president as he does
the old man shuffle uh you know and how
frail he looks now i look at myself now
in the the movies from july 4th my
birthday jumping off boats and stuff and
i i said you know something i'm just not
the person i was it is inevitable this
aging process but wait a minute the
fairness
you had a severe injury so there's a
little bit of a difference
well sure true but and andy is uh eight
months older than i am but look at the
look let's talk about staff for a second
and you talk about clinton and uh joe
was talking about uh ron clinton and the
others
there's no way the democrats can win
without the hispanic vote hispanics are
the the largest minority group in this
country and what jill biden was
attempting to do is to say that
hispanics are within themselves uh we
are a diverse group there's the uh the
puerto ricans of the northeast uh
there's the the cubans of uh of florida
the uh tex-mex from texas all the way to
california
there there are differences my my dad
used to say la unica di farencia entre
nosotros los hispanos es el calor de
noestro frijoles the only real
difference between we hispanics is the
color of our beings the idea being that
this with this the latinos we we have uh
sensibilities and and family values and
and you know we uh religious
institutions and and i listened to you
articulate aware cognitively you're
aware you're on you are the same guy
that you wore 50 years ago when you
started in this business the same you're
as sharp as you've ever been that you
should have made what's that
you know
people people age at different levels i
don't know but how sharp he is
granted and he's not cognitively strong
enough to be president let me give the
last word to joe koncha
well in the end i think guys when you
look at 2024 the democrats are between a
rock and a very bad place kamala harris
is not remotely a good alternative
unless you're thinking of opening up you
know a word salad bar gavin newsom
here's his bumper sticker let me do to
america what i did to california
bernie sanders sure let's have a
democratic socialist president who could
potentially in his 90s in the oval
office the other names unintentionally
hilarious beto o'rourke my senator cory
booker spartacus elizabeth warren if the
plan is let's run somebody who lost to
joe biden in 2020 uh that dog don't hunt
sean geraldo no that doesn't all right
we're going to see very shortly uh joe
concha geraldo thank you both now hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else